Any gathering in person is going to carry some level of risk,...
...but I do think there are ways to do it much more safely.
If you're gathering with people who you really know well,...
...you know their circle of people that they're staying with,...
...then you can be more certain of the risk that you're facing...
...when you get together with them.
If you don't know people well,...
...they may be meeting up with lots of other people who you don't know,...
...and so it's not just your very small circle that you have to consider,...
...but also the many other people that are in their circle.
And we're most concerned about spreading the virus to people...
...who are more vulnerable, who are older or have underlying health conditions.
We know that gathering indoors is much less safe than gathering outdoors,...
...so at any point, if you are going to have a gathering,...
...if you can take it outside, that will always be safer.
Even if you are outside, though,...
...you should still try to maintain that physical distance...
...of greater than six feet as much as possible.
And if you're not eating or drinking,...
...then wearing a face covering, I think, really does offer you some good protection.
We're all under a tremendous amount of stress...
...and it's made even harder...
...without the support networks that we all count on day to day in our family and friends.
So, the more we can practice these public health measures...
...and keep physically distant even when we're together,...
...we'll reduce the risk; we'll break chains of transmission,...
...and you'll also contribute to getting this pandemic under better control.